[Music]  what makes the perfect ride is it a  crisp fall morning or you know sunset on  a summer night is it the thrill of a  downhill coast or the satisfaction of an  uphill battle what about that moment you  passed your first car and smile to  yourself thinking suckers sometimes you  ride because we want to be alone  other times love the energy of the group  and nothing beats conversations over  handlebars because we think their  traffic is exhilarating no scary now  exhilarating um what about that moment  when you match the speed of the wind at  your back and all you hear is the sound  of your tires and suddenly you're flying  that's what makes the perfect ride and  the second you leave the saddle you  start thinking about your next ride  [Music]